welcome to this video when playing sit
for lark I forgot forgot this name
geun-tae by cutter then I am from
Germany let's see the room I have
definitely played him before no
recollection what the line is playing is
playing the exchange and especially
settle this a long time offbeat favorite
of mine the ideas to play Bishop f6 and
cover this so white normally needs to
take it only five to play for any kind
of edge to no Queen age five yeah here
can play g6 or Bishop Bishop e6b should
be success it's also interesting the
intention now Knight f6 because this
night is so ya need some protection so
now I can can take it the e-file is
blocked so rookie one I can um I can
play what is it Queen g4 Queen g6 I'm
not quite sure so to F 525 you know
maybe make sure that they get exchanged
and then i have just i just have two
bishops this is some quite quite a good
opening result this is a strange move
what does he doing I mean the sea to
pawn it's it's not helping at all
k let's develop to 11 possible ideas f
form of course
k f6 should I play F 6 mm and I take
some some porn squares
yeah it's a symmetrical position where i
just have the bishop pam and therefore
i'm black is much better still need some
some good technical play to convert not
sure FC five or so and 96 hoops no no
not c5 I can I shouldn't rush things
here with the two bishops you quite
often need to need to be a bit patient
you and slowly need to increase your
your space and try to make the bishop
stronger but it's often a bad idea to
rush things so take and no no no no this
is good covering e6 and intending c5
like that it is also a good thing that
my king is still in the center of course
so let's let's exchange 11 payoff ropes
and now let's see let's let's put on the
coincide you cannot really play d4 at
the moment okay do for you wants to go
to g4 but it's not great yet there
should be seven threatening age five
hmm
I can also go here the ship fif is not
exactly a great spot
you can I need to get this night out of
the picture
the ship d8 would have been petrella
some okay but they didn't do it I'm
taking a tool so so maybe before symbols
okay so I'd like to get efficient the
eight out of out of the picture
yeah it's not much fun to play this as
white but still it's not fled win at
least with my technical abilities
maybe g 5 wasn't so great
I Scott bishop da tone okay but half
bishop see one I was I was thinking
about Bishop a to be one but Bishop see
what I also have so it's important so I
get to the queenside you want to keep
the bishop maybe I should even just play
the ape on a four to A four and then be
for promoting trying to promote the pawn
yeah he's preventing this idea
so just to see three and then push it
dad should win even if he promotes
should it oops I didn't really didn't
really think about that
check time warning check check white
forfeits on time dad's again again
winning but I completely forgot about
the Jeep on that it's so close to
winning I'm not quite sure what what
what to do yeah yeah here I could I
could I could play a for example I could
place you for you just this one or
Bishop f5 even better just blocking I
just forgot that he's caught yet this is
probably bad idea maybe it's still
winning but it's not not quite clear the
computer says it's winning still winning
but ok it's a bit bit lucky i didn't i
didn't really assess this correctly you
have a very nice endgame but maybe
mistimed with a 5 I don't don't know
it's not necessary to play this I can I
can also first term further improve
we should be six is also possible but
maybe I should have played this
differently right here first improving a
bit more maybe Bishop defy for example
yeah this is an idea to shorten a g5 it
was bad but it still felt like I could
time it better my dear this is a mistake
he should play this one and this is okay
for what just preventing this idea yeah
it's it I miss time that I'm standard
alright thanks for watching